guys and let's be a team and let's
[ __ ] do it okay good night take care
and god bless unhopeful advice we didn't
do that no we did not
yeah on hopeful advice with bobby and
collab oh we didn't do that
hi guys uh my name is dee i'm from
canada
uh kalila or any of you including bobby
have advice on how to live with an
absolute slob i've been living with my
boyfriend for about two years now at
first he was better about cleaning up
after himself but now he has progressed
to the point where he will leave his
dirty underwear everywhere shove garbage
under the couch and leave food out to
the point where we now have mice in our
house every day i discover some new
gross thing on top of that i do all the
cleaning i mean all of it every time i
come home i am faced with some new
disgusting mess or pile up of his [ __ ]
that i need to clean up at first i was
just silently cleaned up after him
because i didn't want to be a nag but
now it's made me feel resilient you're
being appreciated
so i approached him it asked me to clean
up he's gonna leave you because it made
me less stressed his reply was well it
doesn't bother me so why should i have
to clean it get your body so much then
you should clean it that pissed me off
uh how do i get this dirty ass man up
after this oh can i say one lesson
one quick thing and then you can say all
right
if you don't like the smell plug your
nose go ahead
the only reason that i have put up with
his um
disgusting way of life hit it baby hit
it baby
is because he's willing to play pay for
someone to clean in the beginning i did
what you did which was i was just
quietly cleaning everything now it's
like nope i'm not gonna put up with it
if you don't hire someone to clean that
i'm not gonna do it also i'm not gonna
stay yeah there's no way she okay
that's crazy you're right
if we didn't have a cleaner in this
house
we would uh we'd be dead dead being
buried under food and it would be like
well i wouldn't be here um i'm saying me
yeah you would yeah so i just wouldn't
put up with it the hell [ __ ] no and
the fact that he's like i'm okay with it
oh they'll work no you can't you can't
live like that you can't live like that
leave him no do you have a message
because it's so easy i don't know who he
is he's interesting
i don't know who he is if he's he
doesn't have your comfort in mind he
doesn't have your well-being in mind
okay can i just say this though
let me just throw this out all right
hear me out
he's making a mess all over the house
okay
that's true
but we don't know that he if he goes to
work he works at a lab she probably does
too okay i'm saying him let's call this
guy
jackson
jackson my man they're already around
the house but he goes to the lab one day
he finds
the cure for cancer man i believe he's
gonna do it that doesn't mean he's great
to live with it doesn't matter give him
a break he saved humanity
highly doubt that somebody who would let
mike into their action i'm trying but
yeah yeah yeah he sounds like a dick
even his response to you not feeling
good about it the way he's just like oh
it doesn't bother me he's a [ __ ] sucker
leave him boom
there you guys go unless he's like i'm
so sorry like i'm i really did not learn
this when i was growing up like i am a
slob [ __ ] i feel horrible is there i'm
not gonna do it but i'm gonna pay for
someone to do it or can we come to a
compromise then he's not a [ __ ]
but from the sounds of it yeah
just leave him but don't leave him until
you have a conversation
boom
she did and that's what he said
but sometimes women will have two
different conversations there's one
that's
light
and then there's one that's real why
does it have to come to that i need it i
need to get to the reel
so she's like i can't i can't put stuff
away or whatever that's fine i'll be
like oh whatever but it's like
if she has her bags
packed
and it has a u-haul back there and she's
like i'm gone see that's slippery that's
your problem is that you always wait for
things to get so bad before you change
why can't it just be like hey like it's
really like bumming me out like that you
leave all your [ __ ] can i tell you why
pepsi new pepsi new coke what do you
mean new coke right they see they kept
new coke out there for a long time but
nobody liked it what's new you got to
change it you know that's what i'm
saying oh like coke zero instead of yeah
yeah yeah yeah you got to make a
decision you know
i think anyway i think what a beauty
but that's why it's good
all right but anyway lady god bless you
and take care what do you think do you
honestly think she should stay with that
slob i don't know him
he could be islam but he could be the
greatest guy in the world i don't know
him okay bobby is right if he is so
great in all other regards like he is
doting and loving and supportive then
maybe cut him you know give him a break
what if he's a really good artist he
spent so much time in his garage doing
something and he's i don't know what
he's doing you know [ __ ] collecting
mice and he's the nicest guy in the
world he's so he doesn't cheat on her
and he takes her to dinner buys her
roses i don't know what he's like you're
right all right so i'm not going to burn
this guy do a [ __ ] steak like i'm
going to do andrew santino naked i'm
afraid
burns in the flame i'm going to [ __ ]
make a [ __ ] pork sandwich out of out
of fire
anyway i love you guys okay bye
20 22 83 ready to go 22.